grund küste gespannt ich bin ruhig
zukunft mann ich bin jetzt auch ein
bisschen beleidigt mit 20 euro kommt
oder so fällt das lernen sich doch heute
ganz kurz ich habe das video schon
abgedreht leider ist der ton im laden
nicht so nice ich hoffe das könnt ihr
mir verzeihen aber ist es glaube ich
trotzdem interessant geworden und
abonniert auf jeden fall den kanal weil
wir sind bald eine million ein kurzer
klick würde ich mich sehr freuen
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem video viel
spaß althaus geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich es geht euch gut
das heutige video entsteht sehr spontan
sag ich mal ich habe das nämlich gerade
im internet gesehen und dachte mir das
kann ich eigentlich wahr machen und zwar
räumen wir jetzt hier in köln ich habe
angerufen zu media markt fahren weil das
gift wurde in deutschland insgesamt nur
zehn filialen diesen automaten haben und
köln ist mittlerweile als ich habe das
dann irgendwie raus gesuchen und die
haben halt so einbringen also wenn man
in köln gericht drei media märkte und
einer von den hat dass es geht nämlich
um einen sogenannten handy automat das
ziel davon ist oder der sinn davon ist
es da kann man alte handys rainer christ
soll gutschein und kann mit einem
gutschein eingebaut weil wer kennt sich
man hat sein altes handy zu hause rum
fliegen keine aber meinetwegen auch noch
1 von vor zehn jahren war so was man
halt nicht mehr braucht und ich glaube
dafür sind all diese automaten gedacht
und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht dass ich
folgendes mache wir haben jetzt zwei
handys ich habe einmal das hier das ist
von der marke dogde das kommt aus china
ich wollte einfach mal testen ob der
automat auch dieses handy annimmt weil
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das auf was
es wird auf jeden fall auch in europa
verkauft
ich bin mir aber nicht sicher ob das bei
media markt verkauft wird weil kann ja
nur sein dass die nur so registrierte
handys annehmen und dann wollte ich noch
meine eigenes iphone 7 + reinschmeißen
um halt mal zu schauen was ich denn
dafür theoretisch noch kriegen würden
ich habe mir gedacht wir machen das
jetzt einfach mal was später bei
rumkommt weiß ich noch nicht aber es
wird bestimmt unterhaltsam
das ist ja das wichtigste deswegen würde
ich sagen ab geht's ins auto und los zum
mediamarkt denn wir wollen ja völlig
baerchen ich muss auch sagen ich habe
schon ein youtube video dazu gesehen
weswegen ich doch eigentlich auf die
ganze sache aufmerksam geworden bin ich
weil ich das sehr gerne mal in der
beschreibung der täter dann ein samsung
galaxy s 7 glaube ich eingeschmissen und
der automat wollten dafür glaube ich
zehn euro geben wir das oder nicht mal
zehn euro und das ding jetzt ja
eigentlich noch mehr leute deswegen ich
bin mal gespannt was bei meinem iphone
sieben plus das ist das auch wert könnte
man ja vorher mal nachschauen aber
meinst du das ist diebstahl gesichert
weil wenn ich jetzt dein iphone nehmen
würde dann einfach ein verstimmt ich
weiß nicht wie ich schaue einfach mal
wir gucken mal weil ich kann mir auch
nicht vorstellen dass man da einfach
sein handy rein sprechen kann oder 50
euro herauskommen
niemals das löst sich gar nicht lohnen
dann kostet die entfernung des handys
mehr alt keine haben
du kriegst du einen gutschein konstant
einkaufen und die haben ja dann
praktisch das handy und konz
weiterverkauft oder die rohstoffe daraus
nehmen was auch immer ja aber im
endeffekt machen sie ja damit nur kohle
ja da ist es halt ein cooles gadget um
kunden zu locken so wie uns dann nämlich
dann nämlich direkt auch noch die neuen
airports mit
so leute also wir sind sofort hier in
der stadt
also es ist dieser media markt direkt
hier in der innenstadt von köln für die
das vielleicht nach machen wollen oder
so es muss ja auch erstmal funktionieren
auf jeden fall was ich noch sagen wollte
ich wollte jetzt noch gleich mal kurz
schauen was denn mein iphone 7 bei ebay
kleidern wir sind hier an einer roten
ampel da kann ich mal kurz
also ich hätte eigentlich mal so gesagt
ich würde da jetzt noch bestimmt
eigentlich 200 euro für kriegen weil es
ist so ich habe das jetzt eineinhalb
jahre iphone 7 + niemals niemals glück
hier 230 euro 350 euro 320 euro und ich
habe halt auch 100
es wird weiter tschuldigung handy weg
das sagt man nicht leute ich habe aber
auch 128 arbeit das muss ja auch
irgendwie dann vom system erkannt werden
oder
da wird wahrscheinlich dann die
seriennummer gescannt eigentlich bin
echt gespannt wie das funktioniert na ja
ich will jetzt auch gar nicht so viel
aber wir suchen jetzt jemand parkplatz
hoffentlich direkt vom mediamarkt und
dann war das heißt ja immer wenn es hier
so voll ist
um diese zeit so du kannst reinfahren
und dann melde ich mich wieder was ich
habe hier einen guten platz habe ich
diesmal auch geparkt stoppen hatte
natürlich ich zeige euch noch den
parkplatz werden
hier kann man halt optimal parken im
parkverbot und ja schauen wir mal ob wir
hier einen zettel kriegen weil das auch
ein guter guter rat von mir in köln
niemals niemals parkzettel ziehen weil
das kostet drei euro manchmal pro stunde
und dann kann man lieber dann stehen
bleiben weil sonst wenn er erwischt wird
muss es 15 ok los gehts auch so was ich
warte mal ganz kurz wir müssen ja wir
müssen ganz kurz mal hier auf die müssen
jetzt die andere kamera
wir wünschen das war vorsichtshalber
hier auf die kleine camp weil es kann ja
sein dass war drehverbot ist und ich
will ja auch nicht vor irgendwas
abbrechen wir drehen hat einfach gut und
mal schauen wie viel wir für diese story
handy bekommt neuwert 220 euro und für
dieses ei phone 7 jetzt lustig war ja
auch wenn ich da jetzt mein iphone
reinschmeißen und es einfach nicht
wieder rauskommt kids for free na ja das
wäre was für goalie aber darf ich das
rheinstein ist natürlich nur spaß
[Musik]
die tastaturen die haben das nicht so
leise wir haben in automaten gefunden
glaube ich dass man druck machen
was möchtest du machen ich kann den
zustand des telefons beurteilen und die
ein exaktes preisangebot machen oder
wirklichkeit mir dein telefon und legen
dabei welche art telefon möchtest du
verkaufen
während jeder vorne auf die beurteilung
von mit den verbänden und den aufkleber
aus mit denen ich dein telefon
wiedererkennen kann platziere den hof
häger mittig auf der rückseite des
telefons und tippe auf
der anfang wird sich links neben dem
bildschirm ich bin jetzt erstmal mit dem
dorf in dem ich dann telefon beurteilen
amerikas legt aktive folie alter das
erschwert auch für schwer erziehbare
oder weil ich mit der bitte jetzt kannst
du mir 47 prozent mobiltelefone
verlieren ihnen wert noch schneller als
sein
also ich sage der kennt das handy nicht
die story weil es kommen wenn das kennt
stellen wird die sicher dass ich nur ein
telefonat im detail kennt das nicht da
nehme ich meine einfach okay leute würde
ich sagen aber wenn man es jetzt noch
nicht nur iphone
das muss ja gehen welche
in welchem zustand ist gut er sein
telefon nicht und der clip aufkleber auf
welcher party zu deinem telefon
vielleicht werden als nächstes werde
nicht alles gute die leiden erfahren
dass ich es erfahre fassen indem ich den
vorteil dass top dann muss es entspreche
das display suche den gründen stecker
und silin heran um dann telefon
anzuschließen so das vertrauen wieder
einen moment geduld entsprechend ein
telefon und tv hausen
die stadt habe
nach richtiger high tech automaten
perfekt abschließen
sie sagen also ich sage jetzt kommen 150
euro würde ich mal sagen wir seien unter
100 unter 116 geburt gerade dein telefon
modell speichergröße features und
zustand zu lange
jetzt geht schneller und ist gespannt in
die zukunft ich bin jetzt auch ein
bisschen beleidigt 20 euro kommt oder so
das richtig wenn die frage ist entweder
mit leuten auf kleinanzeigen und wo man
streiten oder das hier meine ich weiß ja
was für komische leute schon bei uns
passt dass der preis allein in
deutschland waren 2008 machen
dann irgendwo
das war ja aber ich bin mir da nicht
sicher wenn sie ein foto hoch gelände so
ganz alex wie handy liegt bei 164 4 und
16 ich will oder was machen jetzt da
sind meine ganzen daten drauf alles zu
führen eigentlich müsste das meerwasser
mit instagram account wissen was alles
zu kümmern das kabel nicht wieder
herausgezogen
so leute wir sind jetzt wieder draußen
ich habe das angebot bekommen 164 euro
muss ich sagen hätte ich eigentlich gar
nicht mal gedacht aber wir fahren jetzt
erst mal nach hause weil wir waren auch
so ein bisschen unter beobachtung der
mitarbeiter glaube ich weil wir da
ziemlich lange dort anstanden und zu
hause sagt er noch mal was dazu also bis
gleich okay leute jetzt schauen wir mal
ob er drei euro gespart haben oder jetzt
wirklich 15 zahlen müssen und das sind
kommen wir wieder raus geradeaus aktion
wir sehen uns zu hause habe ich eben
gesagt dass gleich so leute mittlerweile
wieder zu hause
ich habe ja gesagt also ich wollte auf
jeden fall noch ein bisschen was zu
sagen noch macht ruhig für den ton im
laden ich weiß das war jetzt nicht so
gut aber ich hoffe ihr habt alles
verstanden und es war also für mich was
mega interessant was man zu sehen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich weiß
nicht ob sich so ein automat lothar ist
ein hingucker und ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass denn viele leute
benutzen
allerdings glaube ich dass sehr wenig
leute da dann wirklich ihr handy
verkaufen sag ich mal ich habe jetzt für
mein iphone 7 plus 148 g b 164 euro
vorgeschlagen bekommen finde ich an sich
auf jeden fall einen fairen preis muss
ich sagen keine ahnung ob ich auf ebay
kleinanzeigen oder sonstwo mehr kriegen
würde
deswegen also abzocke oder sowas ist das
auf keinen fall könnte ja selbst mal
ausprobieren wenn es bei euch in der
umgebung sondern automaten gibt ich habe
die am anfang ein gebläse in welchen
städten ist die gibt hab mich nur
einbildet gefragt wir haben ja am anfang
auch kurz darüber geredet was passiert
werden so leute halt handys clown und
die in diesen automaten legen und dann
praktisch 150 euro dafür bekommen und an
den gutschein bekommen und damit dann
einkaufen können wobei ich glaube dass
der automat
mal gesagt hat man muss seinen
personalausweis vorlegen aber trotzdem
kann da eigentlich jeder jedes handy mal
eben verkaufen also es war schon sehr
sehr einfach muss ich sagen leider hat
er die story nicht erkannt habe ich aber
auch gedacht dass das nicht
funktionieren wird wer schon krass
gewesen hätte das auch noch funktioniert
weil da ist manchmal wirklich
interessiert was das ding jetzt noch
wert ist aber gut also ich habe mein
iphone auf jeden fall behalten ich hoffe
dass wieder durchgefallen abonniert den
kanal gibt noch nach oben und wir sehen
uns dann morgen meist wieder gibt es
neues video ins koma lag